good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 4666
object class Keter special containment
procedures web traffic and law
enforcement channels worldwide are to be
monitored for evidence of SCP 4666
activity and particularly for cases of
stalking or reports of anomalous
phenomena involving families with young
children should a vies nacht event be
suspected to be in progress the nearest
containment task force is to be
dispatched to attempt containment of SCP
4666 standard pdp-8 humanoid first
contact protocols apply media coverage
of family deaths attributed to SCP 4666
is to be suppressed or falsified to make
set deaths appear as non-anomalous home
invasion murders forensic evidence and
SCP 4666 a instances collected by non
foundation agencies are to be
confiscated and witnesses and Nesta
sized description SCP 4666 is currently
believed to be a single exceptionally
long-lived humanoid entity of unknown
origin survivors of Vice nacht events
typically describe a cp-40 666 has a
very tall between two and two point
three meters elderly male of European
descent with an extremely emaciated
appearance the Antony always appears
completely naked even when observed
outdoors in the freezing weather though
the nature and extent of its anomalous
properties remain uncertain SCP 4666
appears capable of instantaneous or near
instantaneous travel to any location
north of 40 degrees north latitude and
possibly to any location on earth
as CP 4666 activity occurs exclusively
within a period of 12 consecutive nights
every year from the night of December
21st or 22nd to the night of January
first or second this period is known as
SCP 4666 is active phase during this
phase in what are termed vies nacht
events SCP 4666 will appear at 12 in one
or multiple locations north of 40
degrees north latitude in all known vies
nacht events these dwellings have shared
the following characteristics isolated
rural location home to a family with at
least one child under the age of 8 and
situated in an area with snow cover
lasting throughout the duration of the
event vies nacht events consist of the
following general progression nights one
to seven children will report seeing a
CP 4666 in the vicinity of their
family's dwelling the entity will
typically be observed watching the
dwelling from a distance such as from
across a nearby field or from the edge
of a neighboring forest in some cases
children will report waking up at night
to find a CP 4666 watching them sleep
through a window nights eight to eleven
family members including the parents
will report sounds of footsteps coming
from the roof or the Attic an extremely
unpleasant odour will also frequently be
noticed inside the dwelling no cause for
these phenomena will be found as a
result parents will often begin to
suspect their family is being stalked or
even that their dwelling might be
haunted
912 over the course of the night one of
two scenarios will occur the first and
most common is that SCP 4666 will kill
all members of the family save for one
child under the age of eight whom it
will abduct SCP 4666 will inflict
incapacitating injuries to family
members while they are sleeping then
herd them into a single room of the
dwelling where it will proceed to kill
them in view of each other the method of
killing varies with the event and will
typically be preceded by some form of
torture which appears to serve as a
ritualistic purpose see vies nacht
events log below in the second scenario
which has occurred in roughly 15% of
known Vice nacht events SCP 4666 will
not harm the family family members will
report hearing footsteps inside their
dwelling at night though no signs of
forced entry will be found in the
morning children will discover presence
at the foot of their beds these will
consist of toys crudely crafted from the
remains of human children see SCP 4666 a
instances logged below the criteria if
any by which SCP 4666 determines the
outcome of a vice nacht event are
unknown document 4666 5 3 0 0 9 1 lies
knocked events log location unknown
village croatia 1498
description of Lies nacht event
unconfirmed an entire family was killed
with the exception of one of the
children age unknown it was abducted
though specific details about the event
are not available in recovered documents
it was noted that the killings presented
strong pagan mystic elements and that
the family members had been made to
suffer greatly prior to death the
archbishop who oversaw the investigation
wrote that he believed the family had
been killed as part of a demonic ritual
location unknown Village Rupert's land
present-day
Ontario Canada 1689
description of vies nacht event
unconfirmed an entire family was killed
with the exception of two of the
children one of whom was abducted and
one of whom female age unknown escaped
during the killings and was able to
reach a nearby village she told
authorities than a naked man had broken
into her family's dwelling during the
night and proceeded to torture them
exact method not specified in recovered
documents upon investigation the bodies
of the family members were found inside
their dwelling hanging upside down from
the ceiling all had been exsanguinated
location eichstätt germany 1913
description of Lies nacht event an
entire family was killed with the
exception of the youngest child male
aged 3 who was abducted the Bonnies of
the parents and five other children were
found inside a stable adjoining their
dwelling they had been restrained by
having knives pitchforks and other sharp
implements forced through the palms of
their hands and into the walls of the
stable before having their tongues
removed leading to hemorrhaging and
death blood from the family members had
then been used it to paint elaborate
patterns of unknown meaning on the hides
of the mule goat and two cows present in
his stable the animals themselves were
not harmed neighbors told the
authorities that in the week preceding
the killings the father of the family
had mentioned finding tracks in the snow
around the family's dwelling which
appeared to have been made by bare human
feet location pleasse soviet union 1956
description of vies nacht event an
entire family was killed with the
exception of the youngest child male
aged four who was abducted the bodies of
the parents and one other child were
found in the living room of their house
they had been restrained and their feet
had been held over flames in the
fireplace for an extended period of time
calcining the tissues of the feet and
exposing the bones they had then their
heads crushed with an unknown heavy
implement hundreds of bite marks
believed to have been inflicted
postmortem were found on each of the
bodies
branches cut from a fir tree outside the
house had also been placed over the
bodies to unknown purpose location
Scouten ins haven
Norway 1971 description of Lies nacht
event an entire family was killed with
the exception of the second youngest
child female aged five who was abducted
the bodies of the parents and two other
children were found in the basement of
their house each and at least one limb
pulled off by brute force before being
stabbed precisely 39 times with an
unknown sharp implement possibly a piece
of bone from one of the removed limps
resulting in massive blood loss and
death the family members had been
eviscerated and their small and large
intestines removed and cut into 30 to 50
centimeter long pieces these had been
arranged in radiating lines around the
body's feces from the intestines had
been used to trace symbols of unknown
meaning on the walls of the basement
location Eggleston ER iceland 1996
description of Lies nacht event an
entire family was killed with the
exception of the youngest child female
aged four who was abducted the bodies of
the parents and seven other children
were found inside their house all had
large pieces of skin removed from their
backs necks and groins prior to death
removed skin was found to have been
partially consumed they had been killed
by decapitation with a buck saw that had
belonged to the family following death
the family members headless bodies had
been carried into their respective rooms
and placed on their beds each of the
removed heads had also been placed
upright on a step of a staircase leading
from the first to the second floor with
the parents heads on the top two steps
and the children's heads on the lower
steps in decreasing order of age
document 4666 five three zero nine eight
five SCP 4666 a instances log location
nurms finland eighteen eleven
description of SCP 4666 a instance a
small wooden drum with two wooden
drumsticks of uneven length drum skin
consists of a 390 centimeter cubed piece
of skin belonging to a human child
stretched with a thread made from human
tendons location Gallagher Wales 1857
description of SCP 4666 a instance a
small knife 15 centimeters in length the
blade was 6 centimeters in length
sculpted from a single piece of bone
belonging to a human child symbols of
unknown meaning had been carved into the
handle location Makati kazakhstan 1903
description of SCP 4666 a instance a
flute made from the hollowed-out femur
of a human child holes have been bored
at uneven intervals along its length the
femur appears to have been dyed in human
blood
location bangura michigan 1960
description of SCP 4666 a instance a
wooden box containing 13 miniature
human-like figurines each 4 to 6
centimeters in height made from the
phalangeal bones of human children tied
together with strips of human tendon the
figurines had been decorated with human
hair and small pieces of torn clothing
DNA testing revealed that the remains
belonged to 18 separate children
location
cape royal canada 1976 description of
SCP 4666 a instance a ball 23
centimeters in diameter made from 19
layers of human skin wrapped tightly
around the desiccated head of an
unidentified human child male aged 2 or
3 layers of skin are held in place with
pine resin
location barred Netherlands 2006
description of SCP 4666 a instance a
hairbrush the handle is made out of wood
and poorly carved in place of bristles
43 deciduous human teeth have been set
at at regular intervals into the handle
DNA testing revealed that each tooth
belongs to a different child only two of
the teeth could be matched to known
abduction victims of SCP 4666 teeth vary
in age from a few days to over 400 years
discovery SCP 4666 is existence and
ongoing activity were first detected in
1974 through the Foundation's newly
implemented anomalous signature
recognition program when several highly
similar home invasion incidents
resulting in family deaths were found to
have occurred throughout the northern
hemisphere during the night of january
1st or 2nd extensive research into
law-enforcement archives worldwide
eventually uncovered evidence of
probable vies nacht events for nearly
every preceding year going back to the
late 18th century average of 3.1 known
events per year numerous historical
documents were also found which appeared
to describe SCP 4666 activity occurring
prior to this period in some cases as
early as the 2nd century AD in europe
and russia and as early as the 1st
century BC in Scandinavia fingerprints
belonging to the same humanoid entity
have been discovered at the locations of
all foundation investigate advised
nocked events these have been matched to
a partial fingerprint found preserved in
dried blood on a recovered SCP 4666 a
instance dating from 1873 the
fingerprints present characteristics not
known to occur in human beings see image
human-like white hairs were also
recovered from the locations several
vies nacht events though no DNA human or
otherwise could be extracted from them
addendum 4666
oh one on January 2nd 2018 several SCP
4666 a instances were discovered at a
family's residence in Hoonah Alaska
following the conclusion of vies nacht
event number zero six zero one nine
eight among these instances was SCP 4666
a zero nine six zero which consisted of
a crude life-sized doll made from the
emaciated body of a female child to
which the following modifications had
been made a dress made from various
pieces of dirty discoloured clothing had
been sewn around the body and in several
places into the body skin the mouth had
been sewn shut with thread made from
human tendons and the lips painted red
with a solution consisting primarily of
human blood the fingernails of another
child had been glued over the body's
fingernails with pine resin these had
been painted red with the same human
blood based solution three of the body's
fingers were missing the entire scalp
had been removed from the head and the
scalp of another child with long blonde
hair sewn onto the head in its place the
hair had been tied into two braids both
eyes had been removed and to launch
round pebbles on which eyes had been
crudely painted placed into the empty
orbits upon examination by the family
the child from whom the doll had been
made was found to be still alive albeit
unconscious authorities were notified
and the child was airlifted to Bartlet
Regional Hospital in Juneau Alaska where
she survived for 18 hours two foundation
agents were dispatched and were able to
interview the subject see interview log
below following the subjects death
her body was confiscated by the agents
and all witnesses enesta sized as per
standard procedure DNA testing revealed
that the subject had been Ekaterina
Maura's OVA age seven a known abduction
victim of SCP 4666
taken from her family's residence in
dubov Qureshi on January 2nd
sixteen autopsy of the subjects body
showed she had been severely
malnourished during the two years
following her abduction which had
resulted in considerable stunting wait
was only fifteen kilograms height was
only 90 centimeters a number of scars
and burns were present on her skin and
she had suffered two bone fractures left
tibia and left ulna that had not been
reset and had healed improperly hands
were heavily calloused cause of death
was attributed to multiple organ failure
resulting from severe sustained
malnourishment document 4666 five three
five eight one for interview log audio
log 4666 zero six two oh one date
January 2nd 2018 time eleven twenty
seven to eleven forty nine p.m. Alaskan
standard time location Bartlett Regional
Hospital Juneau Alaska interviewers
agent anthony Kowalczyk agent Susan Musa
tending subject Ekaterina Morris OVA SCP
4666 eight zero nine six zero female age
seven notes the subject regained
consciousness for a period of roughly
thirty minutes prior to expiring during
which she was interviewed hospital staff
had previously removed the thread that
had been sewn into her lips allowing her
to speak despite having been
administered a morphine drip the subject
was largely coherent throughout the
interview the subject did not understand
English and initially only spoke a
language that was unfamiliar to agents
Kowalczyk and Muse however after several
minutes the subject began addressing the
agents in Russian which he spoke poorly
agent kowalczyk who spoke rudimentary
russian was able to conduct the
interview without the need for an
interpreter this interview has been
translated by my on-site AI acid playing
log
now hello i am anthony don't you me no I
promise I'm just here to help you you
don't have to
you're safe now Mishka can you tell me
what happened to you do you remember the
ninety came to you underground
you mean in a basement where there lots
of children report
what about you how did this happened to
you
you came to this name hit Club and smash
it and hold do this they F do war I keep
it step lick the toys become the touch
Wow
let's just get rid of this guy's face
off of the monitor and let's all go and
have a really good holiday and just take
our minds off this thing okay
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Saba Maximus Decimus arbiter
Sewell dr. bright darius time Justin day
o philia gray dur nom and jayvo Jack
Corey Barker Arun in and dr. Proctor
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you